[Music]
hi everyone thanks so much for joining
us today
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup i'm rachel i'm calling
in from boston
it's afternoon for me here but
morning for our friends on the call
if you just join now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and say hello maybe where you're
calling in from
but just to go through a brief agenda
we'll have some short introductions of
the meetup and code of conduct
but willie and
nick will share a behind-the-scenes look
at their
road trip app
which i got a first glimpse of last
holiday season and was super impressed
from it and wanted
to see how it how it worked behind the
scenes
we'll also have lots of time for
questions after the presentation as well
but with that i am so excited to turn it
over to
i think you're starting first
to uly first and then nick
yeah hey um
rachel um
uh yeah thanks for the
intro and uh really excited to
actually
chip in with that meet up and to get to
know you all and uh yeah thanks thanks
for joining
and um title for today's session is
under the hood of the aotearoa road trip
and i provide a bit of an intro who we
are and how
we came to
creating
the fp demo today
so we are
we are app interactive and we are based
in new zealand or
the
maori name or the
uh yes so the original name of new
zealand is our terror
and um so we are company here in in
wellington in the capital of new zealand
and we
um
yeah work a lot with r and also our
shiny and so what we are known for so we
create more complex or sophisticated
apps to which often connect research and
science with uh decision making
so um as you do the last couple of uh
years we for for example we are part of
the
new zealand coveted 19 response so we
created a lot of dashboards to help
response services and also create a
dashboard for the general public
or another example you see here is so we
worked together with the minnesota
aquatic invasive species research center
so and to
help decision making around the spread
of aquatic invasive species in minnesota
because they are known for their 10 000
lakes so they're two examples of the
apps we produce
and um
yeah we're a small team here so we uh
got
got some photos here so uh patreon eyes
or we're directors and we um yeah
um
so we
founded a app interactive and we have a
software development team so and our
developer teams are currently five
five staff and nick is one of them uh i
saw also shauna joining so she
hits our design uh ui and ux team
and uh we also have here chris
looks after the admin
so
depending which map you
use so we are actually
in the center of the world so you see
that in the middle
and
meaning we are reasonably close to a lot
of other locations about the closest we
are probably to
um australian so
uh but unfortunately when you look at
some other maps so we often drop off
into the into the right corner there so
which is so a small country in the
pacific but um
yeah so i'm not too sure
uh who
who um
kind of looked a bit closer into new
zealand that maybe some of you guys have
already
traveled there it's actually a really
beautiful country so we've got it's
divided in two islands so we've got the
north island and we've got the south
island
and the top there are some pictures of
the of the south island so we've got the
southern alps and great skiing there and
a really beautiful landscape we've got
nice beaches so i think in the middle is
is golden bay close to nelson
and
yeah on some days you can go skiing in
the morning and go for surf in the in
the afternoon so
great country to live fans i'm
originally from disclosure
um nostalgia i'm originally from germany
but i moved to new zealand around 17
years ago and yeah it's home home right
now
um yeah so we are
um in based in the capital of new
zealand so close to
um so on the so what you see in the
bottom picture so that's the
miramar peninsula so that's where also
better
film studios are located
and so they created for for example lord
of the rings uh who new zealanders uh
believe quite famous for
so um it's um can be
also it can be really nice on a on a on
a calm day but often it's really really
windy and when they google
uh on youtube so the
landings when it's really so when you
fly into wellington so it's quite famous
and there's some really scary readers
out there to to fly into wellington
all right um let's dive into the
christmas tool so and so we would like
to
present you a little bit the
latest edition of it
and uh basically it's it became a little
bit of a
tradition so we end of the year we work
on
get the the team to work on a fun
project so we they can be pretty much
anything so
there can be a short short video clip
there can be just some fun charts
browser games
or
like with it
for for last year shiny applications
and
so we have if you want to have a bit of
a browse if you want to access the
the rt aurora road trip
app
so we've got got the link in the print
presentation and rachel i think we can
share
the presentation with
with the people who are joining today
and
also maybe at this closer we also
planning to put
the code of the app on our github repo
so we're just about stitching that
together because we also want to explain
it a little bit so that that's gonna
come for
um soonish not not not uh ready right
now but it will be uh give give us some
time with it
um
all right um so
the
you should see that so um latest one is
the road trip but there are also other
uh sort of fun
fun apps there so i'd like to
show you
the app um
so i'll show you a little bit around
and um so it's it's a simple app
but what we'd like to demo today is in
particular the javascript integration
and
nick
will
dive into it and shiny provides
actually a really cool framework to to
integrate that and to work on those
um yeah finer let's say finer things in
that we used in the app which make it i
think really really fun to look at and
to use um so it's relatively simple so
we
um
yeah we always brainstorm a little bit
what we
um what we're gonna do um with the app
and uh sort of how we came to it as
we uh
we kind of used a big whiteboard and
then we decided on locations to go on a
road trip and of course last year new
zealand was still
still closed and so we we had to confine
the road trip basically to new zealand
and we selected a couple of
really iconic locations and
so and you can actually go on the trip
so let's start that one
and so we we start basically
from the south of new zealand and then
work our way up uh north so we we start
with uh
um
otago peninsula so we um it's um yeah
very known for the yellow-eyed penguins
and then
so how the app is build up we show
postcards
and then we have uh
yeah a car
on the location
which then moves along so
we um
programmed in a way so you can
click to the next stop and you move uh
to the different location and get a
short explanation of of the location
there so let's maybe just um
a click through it so start with otago
peninsula
and then move up to wanaka so that's uh
yep really beautiful
landscape there it's in the southern
alps and then
we
carry on what you see already there so
we
the car moves and then we also
move the map
alongside so
nick will explain a little bit how we
how we did that and there are also
really subtle things in it so for for
instance the the direction of the car
is
um
moving
you see the the car wobbling a little
bit so that's kind of a fun fun little
thing which
um makes it
make makes it nicer to interact with we
also have that moving background here
um so move our way up so go over to to
christ church and
for those of you now so christchurch was
in a big earthquake
in 2011 and so they
rebuilt the city and also quite famous
is that cardboard
catherine cathedral
so you can move further up to kaikoura
kakou really famous for dolphin watching
and whale watching
and then
go to
wellington
um
on the north island so southern tip of
the north island so that's where we've
got our office set up it's the capital
of new zealand and
government
is located there as well
and then
next one up is oakune so it's a bit of a
ski town
kind of base of mount ropayo and it's
really famous for for carrots so because
they grow a lot of carrots there
and
next stop is
taranaki
and new plymouth so
it's my favorite spot probably to to go
go for a surf in
in new zealand just been there lost last
week actually it's a really great
location move up
and then famous hopkinton from
lord of the rings i think that was
nick's
favorite location
to add to the app
and then last one
up in auckland
and uh sorry
and that ends
ends the journey basically
cool
so
let me go back
so these are the the ones yeah so a bit
of background to it and um these are the
postcards
um with
design so when you look at the app you
will also see
the app is
fully mobile responsive because um
we also of course when you're when you
send out the link and people look at it
so a lot of people these days look uh
check out the the app on their phones so
there was also a requirement to have
that working so we stacked that and
so we did we in parallel we created the
the app um here for for larger screens
but also for more mobile devices and
there so when you look at the codes you
will also see kind of how
how that's done
um
coin
i think nick um
we can probably dive a little bit under
the hood of it
um i
stop
my sharing and uh yeah hand over to you
and um yeah looking forward to see
how it's done
nick
all right
thanks for that early um hopefully the
microphone is coming through the screen
she's coming through everything working
okay thumbs up that's perfect
all right so we'll go now and get a
little bit
under the hood get into the weeds of the
application itself and how that's built
up um so this will be a little bit
swapping between the presentation that
we have here kind of a general overview
and then going into our studio and
looking into the code itself
so starting off kind of some high level
details under the hood so we built up
this application application using our
version 4.0.5
um so at the time i think 4.1.2 had just
come out
around the time when we started putting
this together if i remember right but we
decided to stick with that version
because you know it was it was stable
and we were familiar with it and so we
just kind of used that as our jumping
off point
uh so we also used shiny 1.6.0 for this
one um just generally we try to keep uh
reasonably up to date with the versions
of the packages that we're using and
with shiny that being kind of like the
the backbone of the application so we
try to keep that
relatively up to date um
with the hosting so we have that running
on an aws instance and we have several
applications running on that server so
that's our shiny dot uh episode.com
server that we use to kind of demo
different applications because it's
relatively lightweight we don't need to
worry about giving it like its own
separate instance or anything like that
so we can kind of bundle it up there
with with our other
applications that we
um can kind of keep on there to to put
them out there and test them and you and
run them so that everyone can access
so we have running on that server we're
using the open source shiny server so
that's what allows us to run the
application and hook that up so that you
can access it from the browser
and then with the packages that we're
using it's a relatively confined list
there so using a d-player to kind of
help with a little bit of the filtering
from our location data are we using html
tools and html widgets to help to handle
the
the leaflet javascript plug-in which
we'll get into a bit later
obviously we use leaflet to build up
kind of the the map that we use as the
foundation of our
road trip
then we use shiny to build up the
application structure itself we use
shiny rata to handle multiple pages in
the application because we have our
splash page and we have the actual map
page and then we use shiny js to help us
link in
the
the events and functionality from our
shiny application and so linking that up
to javascript functionality as well
so kind of the key ideas behind the code
base that we're going to talk about
today are to do with modularization of
the code base so that's
splitting out our file structure but
also using uh modules from shiny to
separate responsibilities a little bit
uh the leaflet plugins and javascript
and how we did that for the map is kind
of a big part of it
and so that's a little bit extending
leaflet beyond the basic functionality
of leaflet for r
uh we also
use reactivity so we can so we kind of
stage our reactives and then that helps
us deal with our ui
quite easily
and then the last thing which we'll look
at is a little bit of user experience so
the little changes that we can make
along the way to add up to noticeable
improvements for the user
starting off then with the
modularization and the file structure of
the application so
as a general rule whenever we do a shiny
application we try to follow this ui
server and global pattern
as opposed to
you can also put it into kind of one
file and just use like an app.r and put
all of your ui all of your server into
this one file we like to split it out
into these three separate files so that
your is a really clear separation of
responsibilities
and you know for some apps as they get
larger i'm having it split out into
those separate files then makes it
easier for us to come back later on and
you know debug where things might be
going wrong
important distinction is that we also
try to keep the ui and the server quite
minimal
so you'll see when we jump over to the
code base in a moment that there's
really not that much happening in these
top level files they're kind of setting
up the the basic like the core
functionality the core structure of the
application but we generally prefer to
push out most of the the work that's
happening in these applications
to the
to the different page modules that we're
using or different sub modules
so trying to keep those as minimal as
possible
so we use a shiny router as i mentioned
to handle uh multiple pages and that
allows us to have your meaningful urls
um so that when you're on the splash
page you know you have your home link
and then when you're on the map page you
have another link so if you wanted to
send if you wanted to get someone to go
to a specific page you can just send
them that url and you know they're going
to end up in the right place it's quite
a quite a popular package for us to use
in our applications
from that we also use these page level
modules so in our little diagram here so
we have our splash page and our map page
and we have those kind of set up as
these page level modules
which we then split out into ui and
server files again just so that we can
separate those responsibilities
for those different components
what we also like to do is to have kind
of nested ui outputs
which we'll see when we jump into the
code in a moment but overall
the kind of the main idea with this is
that we want to try and keep it simple
um you know there's there's more
complicated ways that we could set up
kind of the the overall like
modularization and the structure of the
application but yeah we want to kind of
keep it simple because that's going to
make it easier for us to come back to it
later as well
so if i bring up the if i bring up my
rstudio window is that coming through
okay
that's good
good awesome
okay so starting off first with the ui
and server and global so you can see
what i mean here and that there's not
really a lot going on
in this ui dot r here so we're setting
up the page we're loading different
resources that we might need and then
we're setting up the router and
essentially that's it that's all we're
doing in the ui so we're pushing most of
that work out to these page modules
which we'll look at soon
a similar story in the server all we're
doing in here is actually calling the
modules for the different pages so we're
calling for our splash page and our map
page we have this event here to set up
so that when we change pages
um
yeah we scroll up to the top
and then we set up the kind of the
functionality of the router
just a quick
question someone asked if you could zoom
in a little bit
absolutely
zoom in how's that
that's better
okay perfect
and then in global here so this is just
where we're setting up
the libraries that we're using we're
sourcing the different r files that we
need
we have some stuff in here for the
plugin which we'll talk about a bit
later but otherwise we're just setting
up kind of our global variables in here
so that we can then access them
throughout the application and elsewhere
so you can see we've got like a header
set up here this is where we set up the
routes for our
shiny router so that we can then create
it in the ui and the server here
and so with the with the ui so with the
nested ui output so we have the router
being created there and then we'll use
the splash page as an example
so what we said about having like nested
ui outputs so even in the splash page ui
um this is still you're relatively
minimal um compared to what we actually
see on the app so we just have you know
we're setting up the structure of it um
and then we have this ui output for the
page here and so we
actually create that over here in the
splash page server and this is quite a
common thing that we like to do is to
throw the ui parts of the application so
pushing that responsibility over to the
server so this is where we're actually
creating the bulk of the ui for that
page is here in the server in this
render ui block
and so
we do that so that
as we'll see in a little bit later on we
can take advantage of reactivity
and using reactives to kind of help
build our ui
and update yeah without us having to do
too much
so
i guess moving on to the next point uh
the next part of the application the
most interesting part i think uh which
would be the leaflet so setting up our
um
the map which you'll be using for the
road trip
and so we set up the map using
relatively standard uh leaflet for r um
we'll have a look at shortly but then we
do a few other things to kind of get it
to the point where it is in the
application so
one thing you may notice if you are
tinkering around with the application is
that you can't manually move the map so
you can't click and drag on the map
and that's because we have this we have
that disabled so that movement is just
linked up uh to
to you pressing you know the go forward
and go back buttons
so that you don't get lost anywhere on
the map
and then with uh so with the movement on
the map so for the car which we'll
look at shortly so that's kind of a
combination of things which are going
together to do that
so we're using a
leaflet javascript plugin which we
sourced from github
and we're also using observe event and
several utility functions and we're
using shiny js to kind of link those two
together
so
i'll just jump back over to the code
base here and how we actually set up the
map so that's happening in map page
server here
and so if i can find my map
so we have this render leaflet here
and so we have this location data so
this is a reactive which we have set up
um which holds you know the detail about
the different locations and the
coordinates and things like that
and we start off with our first position
so we're isolating that because we only
want this to change when you move
um
and so the first time you know we're
first time we're creating this we want
to use those first coordinates so the
current location data is for the first
location there and then we're setting up
the
uh we're setting up a javascript command
here which we'll use which we'll talk
about uh in a little bit which is how we
actually create the car on the map so
we're setting that up here but then
actually creating the map so which is
called to leaflet
and we set some options here so minimum
zoom maximum zoom
and then we also disable uh dragging
there so that you can't
manually move the camera on the map as
it were
we set the view so we're setting that as
our current position which is the first
location in our location data so we're
setting that view here we're just adding
uh default tiles now you know there is
the option to kind of customize what
tiles we're using but we figured for
this one because we're not zooming in
that far anyway
the default tile set would do quite
nicely actually
and then we have the register plugin
which we'll talk about soon
but we also set up the markers so the
um
the other the x's at the different
locations on the map so we are setting
that up from our location data
uh and we're setting a an offset as well
and that will come in a little bit later
so that the um
so that the car doesn't appear
underneath those markers
and then we're adding the lines in
between all the markers
so we're doing that there so we're just
going through the different uh
coordinates in in our location data and
making some dashed lines between them
which is what we end up seeing in the
application
so
so it's how you get the the map itself
you can't drag
the lines between them the
markers at the different locations
that's all being created in that command
there
so the the interesting part i guess or
the more interesting part about
this application specifically is how we
hooked it up to
these leaflet javascript plugins
because there are limitations to what
leaflet for r can do you know out of the
box so when we're putting this together
we were looking around for ways that we
could extend that and we found a way
that we can use these javascript plugins
and we can add those onto our leaflet
for our maps so that we can actually
access that functionality so for this
one specifically we use the moving
marker
plugin which is available on github here
i'll pop that in the chat as well
so that's um
the plugin that we're using for that
that moving marker and so that's built
for leaflet javascript and so we need to
register that on our leaflet for our map
so that we can then use it
in our application
so we're doing that we're creating
kind of a dependency in global.r and
then we have a function there so that we
can register that plug-in to our map and
so when we're actually creating the map
the first time is where we bind the
plugin to the map
and then we do
kind of an extra step in the on render
of when we're creating that map to help
set up the the marker for the first time
so actually setting up the car
so back into the code we go
and so starting off with actually
registering the plugin
so we have up here so we have this
little utility function that we created
called register plugin which takes the
arguments for a map and the plugin that
we want to register
and it's just adding it to the
dependencies of the map and then
returning the map
so the reason that we have that set up
like so is so that we can hook it into
over here so we can put we can put that
into that kind of pipe so as we're
creating the map we can then pass the
map into this register plugin function
here alongside the plugin that we've
created which we also do over here in
global
so we have this object this
moving marker plug-in which is an html
dependency
and so we're just sourcing the uh
javascript
so we have that we kind of downloaded a
copy of the um
of the moving marker plugin and we just
put that into our resources down here so
in our javascript folder so we have a
copy of that
plugin sitting here
and so we're creating this html
dependency which is just going to source
that
that code
from our from our
file system here
and then allow us to attach it to the
map
so that's uh we're
over here so when we actually call
register plugin and so we're passing in
that
global
html dependency object and so that will
then attach it to the map so that when
we access the map later on we can have
access to all the functionality that we
need
that also comes into this extra step
that we have down here so this on render
so we're saying that when the
uh when when when the map draws the
first time
um so we want to set up
we want to run this this function here
and so we're basically we're creating an
object in javascript um which is the map
that we've just finished making and so
so that we can then access that later on
from our other javascript code which
we're going to use
and then after that we're also running
this js string
as a part of that function which if you
remember up here is this um
it's a call to a javascript function
which which we had set up earlier using
you know our initial position and our
speed and things like that
so in this on render so we're creating
we're making a reference to the map so
we can access it later and then we're
also
running this this javascript function to
actually set up the marker um for the
first time so that we can use it
which then leads into the next point
which is you're creating and moving the
marker so there's kind of two stages to
this and there's a there's a javascript
function which we're going to keep
coming back to
for a lot of this stuff
which is that update car position
um so the two stages here which are
initialization so when we're making it
the first time around and then uh
movement which is yo it's already it's
already been created it exists on the
map and we just want to move to the next
place
so for the initialization so
we create an icon and we assign it to a
new moving marker
and we
set up kind of the the start and the end
behavior for that marker so when it
starts moving and when it stops moving
what should it do
and then we put it onto our map in that
initial position
whereas for the movement so if the
marker is already there and it's already
set up then
we
update the direction so we're using gifs
to handle the direction of the car so we
update that image if we need to
and then we move the marker to the new
position and we also move the map to the
new position
and how that looks in the code so we
have our main.js file here
and then we have these kind of two
stages of it so we have this if init
which was coming in from here so this is
our kind of initial setup phase here
and so in this stage we're creating an
icon
and we're using
uh to start off we use the car facing
lift gif and we give it a size and we
put the anchor in the middle of that so
that it appears in the right place
and then we create a moving marker
using the coordinates which are passed
in to this function
we set the icon for this marker to the
icon that we created here
we give it we give the the moving marker
a much higher offset then if you
remember we set the offset for the
the locations uh we set that to zero as
we set this to one thousand
um probably doesn't need to be that high
but the point is to set it higher so
that when the car is on the map it
always appears in front of
the location markers
and then as a last thing that we do for
setting that up we set interactive equal
to false so that you can't click and
interact with the car on the map
then we set up the uh kind of the start
and end behavior so as i said that's
when the car starts moving or when it
stops moving
and so we link that up to
do some things with our controls so you
may notice in the application when the
car starts moving
when it starts moving these controls get
disabled and then when it stops moving
they get re-enabled
so we set that up in
these on start and on end points here
and so we'll go into that a little bit
later in a little bit more detail i
think
so that's kind of the initial setup of
the car
and then
for the other movement um basically
because we take we have these parameters
so location speed direction
and so for that we're updating the
the image that we're using
we're creating some new coordinates
we're moving the car
to those coordinates
and then we're also moving the map to
those coordinates as well
so
that's essentially how the car is
functioning in in the application
which moves us on to the next point
which is uh to do with reactivity and so
for the sat we
we're tracking a lot of our important
map details
um as reactives and reactive valves so
we have our current location index as a
reactive valve
we have our first and last location
so kind of a little calculation to
figure out if we're at the start or the
end we have those as reactives we have
our location data and our current
location data as reactives as well
and then we also have kind of some ui
parts as reactives too so like the
current postcard and the current
description um which
we'll see in a little bit helps us to
kind of automate the updating the um the
ui
we try to keep the static ui as minimal
as we can as as we've seen so far
and we do that by defining these ui
elements in our server so we use these
render ui and ui outputs and then that
allows us to use reactives and
reactivity to update our ui
so back into the code and in the map
page
server so we have our reactives at the
top here since we have our current
location index and we start off from
whatever this global variable happens to
be which most of the time is one yeah we
can change that for testing but most of
the time we start off at the start
and then we have our first location and
last location reactives which just tells
us if we're at the start or the end
our location data which
takes in our locations which were loaded
in global and then we just do a little
bit of formatting to them
and sorting
and then our current location data which
is filtering this reactive here
to
just our current location
and then the postcard and description
which is pulling the image path and the
description from the location data
specifically
so
these ones in particular are quite handy
because we can yeah that allows us to
kind of we can build our ui using those
elements specifically
so if we're looking to say postcards and
then postcards has
uh some multiple kind of nested stages
so we have postcard front and postcard
back
postcard front here
which we can just use the current
postcards that's that reactive which we
have which holds the the path to the
image
um
and so
that means that whenever that reactive
updates the the ui will update you know
on its own on account of you know the
process of reactivity
and similar thing in postcard back here
where we're using the current
description so anytime
our location changes
the description changes and then the ui
changes so it all kind of happens on its
own
one thing that we like to look at
sometimes with that is the react log um
so you may or may not be familiar with
this but it's kind of a
neat tool for
examining the reactive chain of your
application
um
so i can quickly run that here and we
can see kind of what that looks like so
if i go
there's a react log
enable
and so that kind of sets it up and it's
running and it's waiting and then i just
run the application
this is a local version that we'll have
here
and then i'll just click through a
couple of points here and in the
background the react log is you know
it's recording it's
watching what's happening here it
doesn't really matter what i do too much
but if i bring up
so i come back into here and then i say
shiny
react log
show and so that brings up
react log for this application
specifically
for that session that i just did
and so from this we can see
yeah we can see how the different
reactives and reactive elements link
together so you can see this first here
we have the current location which feeds
into
these reactives here so first and last
location
which feeds into these observe events
and it kind of goes from there so you
can kind of get an idea of what relies
what elements of your
[Music]
reactivity are relying on the other
elements
if you wanted to get really specific you
can click on certain elements and then
you can see
everything that say the current location
data is linked to so you can focus in on
specific parts of your application as
well
and so you can then step through the
different stages and you can watch how
your reactive chain essentially operates
as you run the app
so that's quite a
quite a handy one for us as well
okay
so i think
it's
with the reactivity and then with the
just quickly look at the um observe
events that we have set up so this is
watching these start and back buttons
and reset buttons things like that
and so that's kind of just uh
handling like our ui elements things
like that
for for the back button
that sets up there and then updating the
car position so we're putting together
kind of preparing these different
parameters here
and then we have this function update
static car position which will then
make a call to our javascript as well so
this is kind of all happening mostly in
these observe events here so how we
actually link up those buttons and
user inputs to the
to the car
which kind of ties into the last
few points here which is to do with the
user experience so these are the the
little things that we do along the way
to
improve the overall feel of the
application so things like animating the
car
changing the direction making the map
follow the car
turning off the map interactivity
showing hiding disabling controls based
on the state of the map even like
animating the background which we do
with just kind of your css animations
um so for the car so we already talked
about how we animate the car so
um comes to mind is that the you know
the simplest solution is often the best
solution and we tried a lot of other
more complicated things like you know
inverting the image css transformations
all kind of things like that and then
realize why don't we just use multiple
different images so we have one image
for the car facing left and one image
for the car facing right and so we just
swap between those depending on what
direction the car should be going
because we don't need it to be more
complicated than that and we just assign
that icon to the marker you know as we
saw in that
in the
javascript function here so we just
uh change the source of the icon to
whatever direction we want to go
in um and actually for the direction so
that's calculated um in the
observe events for so when we go forward
or back
um and so we're doing that based on the
longitude i think it's the longitude so
we're just checking is our current
longitude greater than our new longitude
and if it is then the car should be
facing left and if it's not then
it gets calculated in those observe
events and then
feeds into the
into that javascript function to update
the icon
for the map then and the map
interactivity we already looked at
the
the leaflet options so the minimum
maximum zoom and disabling dragging so
that you don't get lost
um
when we make the marker we talked about
setting the interact so disabling the
interactivity for the marker
so we're trying to kind of make it
uh yeah because the overall look and
feel of the application is kind of
themed around this road trip and it's
these postcards so we're kind of it's
it's more of like a look
don't touch kind of thing set up there i
mean you can still zoom in and out a bit
but there's not really anything to be
gained by interacting with the car so we
just disable that to make it a bit
cleaner
um having the map position following the
car movements um
so we're sending it to the so we're
sending the
camera i guess you could call it to the
same position as the car
but
it
at least it feels like it the camera
kind of arrives a little bit faster than
the car does so it's happening in this
step here so with this move too and we
give it a certain speed uh and then the
map panned to
so that's being given the same speed but
it feels like the camera arrives there
slightly faster and that's good because
yeah if if the car arrives before the
camera then you would be able to queue
up more movements while the camera's
still moving and then you'd end up with
some kind of unexpected camera behavior
which we want to avoid so easiest way to
do that is to just make the camera
arrive a little bit first
for the controls so we disable the
controls while the car is moving um so
that also allows us to prevent these
unexpected movements so going off track
um you know just rushing through all of
all of the movements in half of a second
and so we do that again in that
in that
javascript function here so in these
start and end functions here so we're
finding all of those links and then
disabling them when this when the car
starts moving and then again when it
stops moving we're removing that
disabled class from it
actually the other thing that we're
doing in here which is useful for mobile
which is
yeah if so we have a scroll locator so
just like a little invisible element
attached to our postcards so that if
you're on mobile and you're not looking
at the postcards when the car arrives at
the location it will scroll into view so
that you can actually read the text on
the postcards
so that's where that's happening there
and then showing and hiding the controls
based on the map state that
we
are doing kind of in the
in the server parts so we're using
remove ui and insert ui for some of it
and we're also using
kind of run js to handle some of it as
well so at the first position where we
hide the the back button
and then at the last position where we
take away that forward button and we
replace it with a restart button
and so where we're actually doing that
in here in the map page server so we
have
down here so we have is first location
and if it is then we are hiding the back
button so using run js so basically
we're adding that hide class to it so
that it won't be visible
and then at the last location we're
removing the next button and we are
inserting
a restart button instead
so that kind of allows us to customize
the the ui
on the fly depending on
what stages people are at
so that about covers most of the
aspects of the application in a bit of a
lightning fashion um quick summary so we
try to minimize our code in ui and
server we like to have kind of a
modularized code structure
and we prefer to keep things in the
server and use render ui rather than
having your static ui that we can't
change as easily later
um using the leaflet javascript plugins
and shiny which allows us to kind of
extend leaflet beyond the beyond what
would normally be capable out of the box
for leaflet for r
uh using reactivity having lots of
different staged reactors
makes it easier for us to
set up the different
functionality and also updating the ui
and taking advantage of the different ux
features to
really just polish up the you know the
overall what you
what uh what goes back to whoever's
using your application
so that's about all we have for that
we do
as early mentioned this we are planning
on putting this on on our github
we do have some other projects already
available on github so
ipinteractive.github.io
so we have
several kind of little self-contained
examples of things that you can do with
r and shiny
available on there so feel free to take
a look at that um
and
otherwise i think that's about all we
have so
thanks for coming along thanks nick and
um
yeah so we we put up the code so give
give us a bit of time and maybe check
check in in a week a couple of weeks
time and
uh i believe rachel we can also share in
the recording
of the session because you might want to
use some of the methods we showed
and i guess it's a fun little tool but
you can maybe also see it's when you
think about storytelling with data also
so you can
use that probably another context where
you sort of sync up certain explanation
or
outputs with with the map
and and show actually context seo as you
move along so
um
i hope you find that useful um i mean
feel free to connect with us on linkedin
or twitter and so we are quite active
there in so whenever we we have
something available um you would get
that in your feed and i saw that
uh at least i saw one person from new
zealand so we are hosting an event uh
27th of um
of may here in uh in wellington that's
the our exchange that we bring a lot
local community our community together
and uh yeah should be
should be a fun event uh so welcome to
for those of you who are local to come
along otherwise i think we have a bit of
time to uh take questions so if you want
to ask us something yeah
thank you so much and
i always
feel like we need to use these clapping
emojis because you can't hear us
clapping when it's virtual but thank you
so much for a great presentation
i want to um remind everyone if you want
to ask questions you can raise your hand
here on zoom or feel free to use the the
slido link too if you want to ask
anonymously i'll just put it back in the
chat
um
there actually was an anonymous question
which is what i wanted to ask you too so
thank you for this question as well it
was what would you do differently when
you start this project like if you were
to start this project over again
that is a good question um
yeah because
there's there's always there's always
things in hindsight that
you think are
i would definitely change that i think
for me the thing that comes to mind is
probably
um
probably a little bit more following the
dry principle so don't repeat yourself
um so there were certain aspects in in
this code base where we're kind of
you know replicating the same
calculations over and over in different
places so if i was to do it over again
one of the things that i would
definitely try and do
better this time would be to you know
more use of these like utility functions
and splitting things out into into these
functions so that we can just write the
logic once and then just reuse that
rather than having to
um you know run through it and rewrite
it multiple times
i think there could also be a case for
um you know creating like uh going a
little bit deeper into modularization so
having like a separate module for the
map um or something to that effect uh
for next time potentially
i think there was also a question about
um
javascript and for those of you guys who
don't know about javascript because it's
a little bit of a separate thing
probably to r
and uh sort of um and the question was
do you have any recommendation for those
of us that don't know javascript to
start learning enough to do things that
uh
to interact with leaflets so
maybe a little bit what what's available
out of the box to interact with maps i
think that
as i understand the question
so with um with javascript
it is definitely a little bit of a
separate thing um but
because it does tie in quite nicely to
shiny so i think we find that as as you
kind of progress with shiny
you kind of pick up little bits of
javascript along the way um just because
it can be quite a handy kind of work
around to certain aspects um
in terms of like
what's a resource for
for getting that understanding
i i'm not 100 sure off the top of my
head i i'm quite fond of things like uh
like code academy um i i know they have
quite good courses on on things like
that but uh
yeah i think a lot of a lot of it uh for
for shiny specifically is kind of just
it came up along the way and we kind of
just add that to the list of things that
we can do you know
thank you
uh let me go back over to slido and see
there's another question that was how
long did it take to complete the entire
project
it was a relatively quick turnaround on
account of it being so it's kind of our
end of year
um project um
and so we would like send that out to
people that we work with throughout the
year so we need to have that ready
before everyone's gone on their
christmas holiday
um
so i think because there was also kind
of a design phase to it um
what would i be writing saying probably
about a month overall really
yeah
probably and um yeah so there was a bit
of design
part up front um we
would like to put a bit of thought
um in it beforehand before you really
start coding
and um so we i mean we're glad to have
um um
with shana
ux and ui designer on board and we like
um to use adobe xd
quite a bit so that's a that's a design
program and you can specifically for web
interfaces where we can draw out the
interface so
that typically speeds up the development
process quite a bit because it's clear
via certain elements uh sit so you don't
need to
go backwards and forwards a bit so we
i think we had to adjust things a little
bit like with the car movements or so so
yeah we didn't quite know
what was pos um possible with
relatively
uh let's say
a relatively low effort because we it's
a it was a side project of us
and um but then maybe development time
but maybe a week
design and think about it and then
um three weeks or so to
develop it um probably not full time but
uh a bit bit on and off yeah so
um
yeah really relatively confined project
that's one of the other good things
about these yeah our christmas uh
christmas tool tradition so it kind of
gives us the opportunity to experiment
with things that maybe we wouldn't
normally
get to try
so
it's quite a fun one always when it
comes around
that's awesome i see will you have a
question yeah can you guys hear me all
right yep
um
i had a question for nick on the
ui where you said to keep it in the
server function then i think you passed
it to the
keep it in the server module module pass
it to the ui module via render ui
that's so that you don't have to be
passing data between those modules so
that it's all just in that server
function was that
correct yeah yeah so
so that we can use the reactives that we
have and and
um so with with uh the ui outputs and
render ui so that is
it's like a vel it's a valid reactive
context so
the the main reason why we do that is so
that we can use those reactives to
either decide on what parts of the ui
we're going to show so we can
conditionally show certain parts of the
ui or in this case we have them kind of
directly going into
into parts of the ui so we're pulling
that text out of the um
out of the location data and putting it
directly into the ui um so if we were to
do that in
you know in the ui part of the
application so that's kind of static we
would have to be you're updating that
manually
but yeah so why we push it always to the
server or we prefer to push it to the
server is so that
we can have access to
it's not just the reactives as well we
can we can do you know we can use um so
we can do regular r functions
calculations things like that that we
can then tie into it
so it's kind of just expanding our
options by doing that
awesome things
there is there are things to watch out
for um not so much in in this one but
generally
um
so things like if you have uh
uh so like uh inputs like drop downs or
sliders or things like that if you're
creating those in your server then you
might need to do things like making sure
that those things have actually been
created before you use them
so there are there are trade-offs to it
but overall
that is kind of the approach we favor
great thank you
i was
curious do you use some of these apps to
show
customers what's possible or
i think a lot of times people
like on the data science hangout will
ask questions around if they're
interviewing for a role and they want to
be able to show apps that they built
it's great to have toy examples
available as well so just curious if you
use these with clients
um yeah sometimes when when you come
like
mention sort of storytelling with data
sort of may um maybe show
kind of how
you can sync up
certain elements and maybe also interact
with maps so
we we have that suite of tools and
sometimes we pull it pull it out of our
sleeves and
show at least elements of it yeah so
they can be quite useful and
maybe having a little bit those um
passion projects running on the site can
be quite useful just to expand a little
bit what what you typically do
so that your and and that
tends to then so we when we
explore and dive into other things it
tends to influence other things as well
so because we knew okay that's possible
we knew i had to do it we use it in
other projects as well so it's uh
we found it always good to have
some some patient projects running
wherever you're in it or have an idea
and then tinker with it and that flows
then into into other things as well
yeah that that's great i was looking at
it thinking it'd be really cool to see
like a customer journey map as well or
something like that
yeah i hope that sparks some ideas so
when we've got the code out there or
um feel free to use ideas and help its
box kind of using it in your own project
and get a map moving or to
plot maybe some animations on the map so
i hope that sparks some ideas
with your projects as well
but thank you so much julie and nick
that was amazing
i'm excited to be able to see the code
too
awesome welcome and uh yeah nice nice to
meet you all and thanks for joining
thanks for having us
[Music]